Hi, I'm John Green, this is Crash Course World
History, and today we continue our discussion
of how a regional conflict became World War
I. We're also going to look at who started
the war and although no one nation is truly
to blame, some nations are more to blame than others.
Like America, for once? Blameless. Well, not
totally blameless. Largely blameless.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green! That's easy, the Germans
started the war.
Well, Me from the Past, as it happens many
historians and British politicians would agree
with you. I mean, you have an opinion that can be
defended. And I can't wait for you to defend it.
Uhh... maybe they just, like, really liked war? I'm
not really in the defending positions business,
Mr. Green, I'm more in the like, bold proclamations
business.
Yes, Me from the Past, noted. But it turns
out, there's more to life than that.
So the topic of who started World War I remains
one of the most controversial and interesting
topics to discuss in World History, not least because,
you know, we'd like to avoid having another one.
But in general, when we talk about World Wars,
as when we talk about World Cups, we pretty
quickly end up discussing Germany.
The idea that the root cause of World War
I was Germany, or more specifically, German
militarism, continues to be popular. This
has been the case ever since the 1960s when
this historian, Fritz Fisher, identified Germany
as the chief cause of the war. But Germany's
guilt for the war was also written into the
Versailles Peace Treaty, in article 231, and
most of you will be familiar with the idea
that anger over that clause its incumbent
debts helped lead to Hitler's rise.
Also, pretty much however you slice it Germany
was definitely responsible for starting World
War II, and looking back that made it more
plausible that they would have also stated
World War I, because, you know, they had a
history of starting wars. To be fair, the
definition of a Western European nation is
"has a history starting wars."
Unless you're the Swiss.
Cue the Switzereel, Stan!
Yeah okay, but the thing is attributing characteristics
like militarism or authoritarianism to entire
national populations is a little problematic.
Also one nation's militarism is another nation's
strong national defense, and when you live
in the country, as I do, that spends more
on defense than any other nation, it's probably
not that good of an idea to call people militaristic.
There's just something about that broad-brush
painting of an entire nation sharing a particular
characteristic that feels a little bit propaganda-y.
Also, it wasn't just Germans who were militaristic
in 1914. The idea of "the glory of war" was
a very popular concept all over Europe, and
really there's no evidence that the German
people of 1914 were any more or less militaristic
than the French or the Russians, They all
had poetry that celebrated heroic sacrifice
and dying for the Mother and/or Fatherland.
That's not usually and. Maybe, though. I'm
gonna stay open minded.
But there's another problem with the whole
idea that the Germans were more eager for
war than anyone else in Europe. That argument
relies a lot on the behavior of Kaiser Wilhelm
II, the German leader, and the Kaiser did
make some pretty bellicose and stupid public
statements, which in turn made people fear
that Germans were eager for war. So Wilhelm
became kind of a stand-in for German aggression,
a literal cartoon villain, upon whom the world,
especially the English, could project their
stereotypes.
So I would argue that the German character
isn't to blame for World War I, and in fact
no national character has ever been to blame
for any war. But I am not going to let the
Germans off the hook entirely.
So you will remember that Germany offered
the so-called "blank check" that Germans would
always support Austro-Hungarians' ultimatum
to Serbia. And in some ways this empowering
by Germany's support encouraged Austria's
foreign minister Berchtold to behave as recklessly
as possible, under the mistaken impression that
this is what the Germans wanted him to do.
So basically, Austria thought that Germany
wanted a war, so they were like, "Oh, we'll
just behave really recklessly and we'll give
the Germans the war they've been so excited
about." But the Germans were offering the
Austrians the assurance of support in the
hopes that it wouldn't lead to war.
So you could argue that in fact most of the
blame for starting World War I should fall
on the shoulders of the Austrians, after all,
they were the ones who issued the ultimatum
to Serbia, and they were the first to declare
war, although only against Serbia. But, the
Germans were the first to declare war on a
major power, Russia, on August 1st, and the
German advance on France through Belgium is
what brought Britain into the war. And those
are pretty solid arguments that Germany turned
the conflict from, you know, a regional thing
in the Balkans, which isn't unprecedented,
to like this big pan-European war.
But I don't think we're done assigning blame,
because we didn't just have a pan-European
war, we had a world war. Russia.
Now you'll remember that of all the major
powers, Russia was the first to mobilize its
massive army, and it was Russia's mobilization that
drew Germany, France, and Britain into the war.
Putin is looking at me, isn't he, Stan. I'm
just trying to--ah! you so scary!
Stan, can you please make Mr. Putin go away,
I'm just trying to talk about history, I'm
not talking about any current conflicts.
And it makes me nervous to say this, but there
was really no good reason for Russia to mobilize
in the first place. I mean, when Austria declared
war on Serbia on July 28th, the Austrians
could not mobilize their own troops for two
weeks, because they were on harvest break.
I mean, if we've learned anything about agriculture,
it's that it's hard to have a large-scale
war without it, so we can't go to war until
all the wheat has been farmed.
But even if Austria had mobilized and attacked
immediately, their initial plan was an attack
on Belgrade, not Russia, which by the way
was called somewhat confusingly, Plan B. Now,
Vienna did have a plan to mobilize against
both Serbia and Russia, but they never used
it. But even if Austria had launched an all-out
attack on Russia, Russia had begun its pre-mobilization,
the period preparatory to war, on July 25th,
and while I usually don't care about dates,
with the start of World War I, very important,
because July 25th was before the Serbs had
even responded to the Austrian ultimatum.
And just as a general rule, it's hard to play
the blameless victim when you're moving all
of your troops to the border. Hey, why are
you here again, Putin?
So here we have Austrians and Germans receiving
reports of Russian troops massing on their
borders, and you know, that seems kind of
like war. A lot of it comes down to how you
understand Russia's period preparatory to
war. I mean, do you focus on the "period preparatory",
or do you focus on the "to war"? Regardless,
Russia became the first power to actually
put its war machine into motion.
Let's go to the Thought Bubble.
So talking about Russia leads us to some of
the more meta arguments about the causes of
World War I because it's difficult to understand
what Russia was doing when it mobilized without
trying to understand why they mobilized. After
all, an Austrian attack on Serbia was hardly
an existential threat to Russia, I mean, look
at the map. Russia's huge, and at the time,
probably had the largest army in Europe, if
not the world. So why would they care about
what was likely to be a skirmish on the Bosnian
border?
Well, here's where geo-politics and history
come in. So, looking at the map, you can see
that the Balkans are right next to the Dardanelles,
the straits that give access to the Black
Sea. Russia needed to maintain influence there
in order to ensure traffic through those straits,
especially if the Ottomans were going to form
an alliance with the Germans, which they did.
Also, at least in its own estimation, Russia
was in danger of becoming a laughingstock
in European politics: their humiliating loss
to Japan in the Russo-Japanese War was followed
by Russia's inability to stop Austria from
annexing Bosnia from the Ottomans in 1908,
and that was the event that sparked Serbia's
drive to expand its own territory. Its history
of prior weakness meant that Russia's foreign
policy makers feared that without some decisive
action, Russia wouldn't be taken seriously
anymore.
In the wake of Austria's ultimatum, Russian
foreign minister Sazonov concluded that Russia,
quote, "Could not remain a passive spectator
whilst a Slavonic people was being trampled
down. If Russia failed to fulfill her historic
mission, she would be considered a decadent
state and would henceforth have to take second
place among the powers...if at this critical
juncture, the Serbs were abandoned to their
fate, Russian prestige in the Balkans would
collapse utterly."
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
So judging from what we just learned in the
Thought Bubble, it was really the Ottomans.
If they could have just stopped Austria from
annexing Bosnia in the first place, none of
this would have happened. And if I may go
a little further back, there wouldn't have
even been an Ottoman Empire without the stupid
Romans. And of course the Roman Empire was
largely dependent upon constant expansion
and looting, so if only the Gauls could have
defeated Caesar, none of this would have happened.
In short, no wonder Caesar was assassinated,
he was about to start World War I in 1900 years.
I bring that up because that's the tricky
thing about the blame game. You can trace
the causes of World War I back a bunch of
ways. I mean, I can't think of anyone who
you can't at least partially assign blame
to - well, I mean except the Mongols.
Actually you know what, if they'd just kept
control of Russia, probably no World War I.
Anyway, all of this only scratches the surface
of the arguments about who's to blame for
World War I. I mean, I haven't dealt with
stuff like the alliance system or European
imperialism, or you often hear about the naval
rivalry between Britain and Germany, and then
there are the ideological causes, like nationalism,
and the Social Darwinist thinking that led
people to believe that war was a natural and
inevitable state of human affairs.
You can tell all those origin stories of the
Great War, and they're important, but ours
centers on diplomatic history. There are a
few reasons for this, first, the decision
to go to war was ultimately in the hands of
a very small group of diplomats. I mean, even
in the most democratic countries, Britain
and France, popular opinion didn't force mobilization.
Also, in most countries that's still the case.
It's still diplomats who decide whether to
go to war. So understanding what makes governments
and diplomats decide to go to war is very important.
But looking at the diplomatic causes of the
war also reveals something to us about the
pitfalls of writing history. I mean diplomats
are famous for keeping pretty detailed records
of their dealings, both at the time and in
retrospect, and then historians have to sift
through all these sources and make choices
about which ones to emphasize. And sometimes,
even which ones to believe, because of course,
often these sources are in direct conflict.
Now, I'm no historian, but in creating this
episode, we had to make choices that many
of you will disagree with. Either because
you don't think we gave enough evidence or
because you don't like the things that we
emphasized, and that's great. It's these constructive
and critical conversations that lead us to
dig deeper, to consult more primary sources,
to read more broadly, and that in turn leads
to a richer understanding of the world and
a more engaged life.
All that noted, the alliance system was certainly
important and I'm sure you'll be discussing
it in your classes, and in comments.
Thank you for watching, I'll see you next
week.
Crash Course is filmed here in the Chad and
Stacey Emigholz Studio in Indianapolis, and
it's made possible because of these people's
hard work and also because of your contributions
on Subbable. Subbable is a voluntary subscription
service that allows you to contribute directly
to Crash Course for the monthly price of your
choice and it allows us to keep Crash Course
free for everyone forever, so thank you to
all of our Subbable subscribers, and thanks
to everyone who watches.
As we say in my hometown, don't forget to
be awesome.